THAT AND MORE IN BREAKING NEWS,
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
>> THE LEFT ARE GOING INSANE
OVER REPORTS THAT THE NORTH
KOREAN DICTATOR KIM JONG-UN IS
THREATENING TO PULL OUT OF THE
PLANNED SUMMIT WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP OVER U.S. AND SOUTH KOREAN
MILITARY DRILLS.
NOW KIM JONG-UN REPORTEDLY CANS
ENDELED TALKS WITH SOUTH KOREA
NOW BEFORE ALL OF YOU LEFT WING
LIBERAL ACTIVISTS WORK YOURSELF
IN A FRIENDSY I WILL GIVE YOU
THE TRUTH AND FACTS.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS SAYING
THIS THIS SUMMIT IN SINGAPORE IS
GOING AS PLANNED.
AND THE PENTAGON IS ADDING THE
MILITARY EXERCISES WILL
CONDITION.
TAKE AWAY THE LEFT REFUSED TO
UNDERSTAND IS THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WINNING
WITHOUT GIVING NOTHING UP IN
RETURN YOU IDIOT IDEAING ONES
YOU NEED TO WATCH, LEARN, HOW TO
NEGOTIATE.
THE PRESIDENT GOT THREE AMERICAN
HOSTAGES OUT AND DID NOT HAVE TO
SEND OVER CARGO PLANES FULL OF
CASH LIKE OBAMA DID WITH THE
MULLACE.
NEW IMAGES ARE SHOWING NORTH
KOREA IS ALREADY DISMANUALING
THEIR NUCLEAR TEST SITE.
KIM JONG-UN IS INVITING THE
WESTERN NEED MEDIA TO WATCH.
ALSO YOUNG YOUNG, YES WHAT, HE
IS NO LONG ARE FIRING MISSILES
OVER JAP PAN NOT THREATENING THE
U.S. AND THE REST OF THE WORLD.
AND YES, YOU SAW IT WITH YOUR
ICE,INGS ROCKET MAN WALKED
ACROSS TO GREET SOUTH KOREA'S
PRESIDENT WHAT DID PRESIDENT
TRUMP GIVE UP?
NOTHING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT NILE EVE
LIKE CLINTON, OBAMA.
THEY TRIED TO BRIBE THE
DICTATORS WITH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE IS
TYPICAL REAGAN.
TRUST BUT VERIFY IN ACTION.
KIM JONG-UNMENTS TO COME TO THE
TABLE, FINE.
WE KNOW THE SECRETARY OF STATE
LAID OUT OWL THE DETAILS FOR A
POSSIBLE AGREEMENT THAT INCLUDES
COMPLETE AND TOTAL DE
COMPLETE AND TOTAL D
DENUCLEARIZATION.
LITTLE ROCKET MAN DOES NOT WANT
TO COMPLY HE HAS TO FACE THE
CONSEQUENCE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE CLEAR NORTH
CREEAL NOT GET AWAY WITH
THREATENING THE WORLD AND NOT BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP A WEAPON.
HERE IS MY PREDICTION.
KIM JONG-UN WELL, HE IS BEING
POSTERRING AND DURING SAT ARE
RALING BEFORE HE GUESS TO THE
TABLE.
MORE BREAKING NEWS TO IT WILL
YOU ABOUT.
TRUMP'S ATTORNEY IS TELLING
MEANS PEWS THAT HE HAS SPOKEN
WITH MUELLER AND HIS PARTISAN
TEAM OF WITCH HUNTERS AND NOW
SAYING THAT A POTENTIAL
PRESIDENTIAL INTERVIEW IS PUT IN
A HOLDING PATTERN.
IT IS GREAT NEWS.
MULL ARE HAS NO BUSINESS
QUESTIONING THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
COLLUSION.
THERE MIGHT BE WITH MUELLER AND
THAT GUY I WILL EXPLAIN.
THE LEAKED SPECIAL COUNCIL
QUESTION ASKING TRUMP, HOW DID
YOU FEEL.
RIDICULOUS QUESTIONS HE IS SET
NOTHING THE CASE OF PURGE REAL
TRAP.
NO GOOD LAWYER WOULD LET THE
LAWYER BE INTERVIEWED.
THE PRESIDENT IS CONDITIONING TO
KEEP HIS PROMISES TO YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN THE
MEDIA NEVER THOUGHT WOULD SHOW
UP.
NOW CALLING ON CONGRESS TO DO
THEIR JOB.
SECURITY BORDER.
DO IT NOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FIRST DUTY OF GOVERNMENT
IS TO PROTECT OUR CITIZENS AND
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF DHS, ARE ON
THE FRONTLINES OF THIS
INCREDIBLE HORRIC FIGHT.
>> THAT IS WHY WE ARE CALLING
ON CONGRESS TO SECURE OUR
BORDERS, SUPPORT OUR BORDER
AGENTS, STOP SANCTUARY CITIES
AND SHUT DOWN POLICIES THAT
RELEASE VIOLENT CRIMINALS BACK
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE DON'T WANT IT ANY LONGER.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALREADY
AACCUMULATED AN AMAZING RECORD
RESIDENCE ARE SMART THEY RUN ON
IN NOVEMBER AND THIS WOULD JUST
BE ANOTHER KEY VICTORY.
LOOK AT THE ECONOMY.
RECORD LEVELS.
OPTIMISM AT 11 YEAR HIGH.
PRESIDENT'S NUMBER THE HIGHEST
IN HIS PRESIDENCY.
THE IRANIAN DEAL ON THE EMBAS
NEJERUSALEM.
TACK CUTS AND KILLING THE OBAMA
CARE.
BITE WAY.
IT HAS NOT BEEN TWO YEARS.
ALSO TONIGHT.
RUSSIA IS UNRAFFLING AS WE
PREDICTED.
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
HAS WITCH HUNT.
SAYINGS
>> YOU KNOW I LIKE TO DO THIS
OO00 WE HAVE YET TO SEE ANY
CREDIBLE EVIDENCE OR
INTELLIGENCE THAT LEAD TO THE
OPENING OF THE INVESTIGATION.
>> I BELIEVE THEY NEVER SHOULD
HAVE OPENED A CERNEL
INTELLIGENCE
INTELLIGENC
INTELLIGENCE INVESTIGATION.
THE INVESTIGATIONS ARE VERY
RARELY DO THEY HAPPEN.
WHEN THEY DO HAPPEN YOU HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL BECAUSE YOU ARE USING
SERVICE IN RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES TO SPY ON A
CAMPAIGN.
THE TOOLS OF
THE TOOLS OF IN
THE TOOLS OF INTE
THE TOOLS OF INTELL
THE TOOLS OF INTELLIG
THE TOOLS OF INTELLIGEN
THE TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE
THE TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE A
THE TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE AND
THE TOOLS USED AGAINST
AMERICANS.
NO, THERE WAS NEVER ANY CREDIBLE
EVIDENT TO LAUNCH THIS
INVESTIGATION.
ROD CONFLICTED THIS .  IS A
STUNNING STATEMENT BY DEVON.
AND THAT'S ON TOP OF THE FBI,
DOJ, LYING, MISLEADING.
FILESA JUDGES.
MULTIPLE TIMES.
IN ORDER TO GET A WARRANTY A
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE WEEKS LEADING
UP TO AN ELECTION AND FOR A YEAR
FOUR JUDGES LIED TO.
THEY WERE NEVER TOLD THE TRUTH
AND BOUGHT AND PAID FOR NOT
CORROBORATED.
>> WELL IS A FLEW DI
>> WELL IS A FLEW DYN
>> WELL IS A FLEW DYNAM
>> WELL IS A FLEW DYNAMIC
>> WELL IS A FLEW DYNAMIC N
>> WELL IS A FLEW DYNAMIC NOW
THE POSSIBILITY OF AN FBI MOLE
IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE CHAIRMAN IS INVESTIGATING
THIS DEVELOPMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU HAD FUSION GPS HIRED
BITE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO DRAW UP
SOMETHING AS THE PRESIDENT WAS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT IN HIS
TESTIMONY, HE MENTIONED THAT
THERE WAS A SOURCE WITHIN THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> GLEN RUNS -- GLEN SAID THAT
IN PUBLIC CLOSED TESTIMONY AND
BECAME PUBLIC NOW CONFIRMED HE
WAS TELLING CONGRESS THE TRUTH
WHICH IS GOOD.
WE BELIEVE
WE BELIEV
WE TELIEV
WE TELLEV
WE TELLIN
WE TELLING
WE TELLING T
WE TELLING THE
WE TELLING THE T
WE TELLING THE TRU
WE TELLING THE TRUTH
WE TELLING THE TRUTH.
WE ARE GETTING THE DOCUMENTS TO
FIGURE OUT DID THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE WHAT MANAGEDS WERE USED TO
OPEN THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> THAT IS AN AMAZING
STATEMENT.
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING THIS SCANDAL
IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
SCANDAL AND CORRUPTION SCANDAL
IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND THAT WE HAVE BEEN UNCOVERING
THIS AND PEELING BACK THE ONION
THIS IS THE BEGINNING.
YOU GOTTA SIT TIGHT EVERYTHING
THAT THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU FOR OVER A
YEAR IS GETTING FLIPPED ON ITS
TODAY AND ALL OF IT AS WE TOLD
YOU IS BOOMER ANXIETYING BACK ON
THEM.
THE REAL RUSSIA SCANDAL IS
SPANNING THE WITCH HUNT IS
CRUMBLING.
LET'S ANY THROUGHOUT HEADLINES
AT MUELLER'S PROBE FIRST TRIAL.
EXPECT MORE BLUNT LET THE RECORD
REFLECTS FROM THE BENCH.
THAT JUDGE THE THIRD ALREADY
SMACK DOWN IN EPIC FASHION.
MUELLER'S TEAM CALLING THEM OUT
FOR TRYING TO FLIP PAUL
MANFORTON AN EFFORT EFFORT
UNRELATED WITH THE UKRAINE AND
TAX FRAUD WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH TRUMP, RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THE RUSSIA TIMES MULL ARE TRYING
TO JUSTIFY HIS EXISTENCE AND
INDICT A RUSSIAN.
ANY RUSSIAN.
THE POOR TRANSCRIPTS SHOW ROBOT
MUELLER INDICTED A RUSSIAN
COMPANY.
IT DID NOT EXIST AT THE TIME
THEY SAID.
NOW THIS IS SHOWING THAT
MUELLER'S ORIGINAL INDICTMENT
WAS AN ELUSION TO MAKE IT SEEM
THERE WAS A COLLUSION.
MUELLER NEVER PARTICIPATES THE
RUSSIANS WERE GOING TO CALL HIS
BLUFF THIS WAS AN EMBARRASSMENT
FOR HIM.
NOW THERE ARE THE SPECIAL
COUNCIL THEY LOOK FOOLISH HIS
TEAM WAS NEVER PREPARED IT WAS
FOR SHOW.
YOU WORK OUT WITH THIS PIECE.
ONE YEAR DOWN IT IS MUELLER TIME
AND WRITES THAT RUSSIA PROBE HAS
BEEN GOING ON FOR THREE YEARS
WELL IS NOT ONE INDICATION WHAT
THIS INVESTIGATION IS REALLY
ABOUT.
HERE IS WHAT WE DO KNOW.
AFTER ALL OF THIS TIME TLSHG IS
ZERO EVIDENCE OF TRUMP/RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
IT HAS BEEN A WITCH HUNT IT IS
AND A TOTAL SHAM.
AND FOR THE SAKE OF THE COUNTRY
IT NEEDS TO END WOULD FEEL VERY
WELL KEY UPDATES TO JOHN
SOLMON'S REPORT THAT WE BROUGHT
YOU LAST NIGHT ABOUT THE FBI
DIRECTOR MUELLER WORKING WITH
THE RUSSIAN BEEN
THE RUSSIAN BEE
THE RUSSIAN BIL
THE RUSSIAN BILLI
THE RUSSIAN BILLION
THE RUSSIAN BILLIONAI
THE RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE
THE RUSSIAN BILLIONAIR
THE RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE.
NOW PART OF THE INVESTIGATION.
HE WAS WORKING WITH HIM.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
WROVENLG I WILL DEFEND MULL OR
THIS.
HE AND OTHER FBI AGENTS THEY
WERE TRYING TO FREE A FORMER FBI
RETIREE A CIA OPERATIVE FROM
IRAN.
HE WAS HELD HOSTAGE.
I'M HAPPY THAT HE WAS WORK WIDTH
RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE.
THAT HE SOMEHOW CONVINCED HIM TO
GIVE HIM 25 MILLION DOLLARS TO
SAVE AN AMERICAN HELD HOST
ANNUAL I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE IN THAT
SITUATION.
I WILL GIVE MUELLER CREDIT.
IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
HERE IS THE ISSUE IT IS A
MASSIVE CONFLICT OF INTEREST
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL MUELLER'S
RUSSIA COLLUSION F. YOU TALK
ABOUT A GUY IN A MANFORTCASE
THAT YOU WORKED WITH AND SECURED
25 MILLION DOLLARS FROM YOU NEED
TO REVEAL THAT.
JOHN REPORTING THAT RUSSIAN IS
THE FIRST PEOPLE THE FBI
INTERVIEWED WHEN THEY BEGAN
INVESTIGATING THE CLINTON'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DALLASIEL.
THE RUSSIAN TOLD THE FBI THE
IDEA OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION WAS
FALSE.
NOUGHT QUESTION IS, DID THE FBI
IT WILL THE FILESA COURTS A
FORMER TRUSTED SOURCE OF THEIR'S
TOLD THEM THERE WAS NOTHING TO
THIS RUSSIA COLLUSION WHEN THEY
APPLIED FOR THE FOUR WARRANTIES
THE ORIGINAL APPLICATION AND
THREE SUBSEQUENT ALL USING THE
BULK OF INFORMATION FROM THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
UNVERIFIED PAPER WITH RUSSIAN
LIES THEY LIE TODAY DID IT TO
THE COURT TO SPY ON AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
ANOTHER DEVELOPING STORY.
THE MEETING WITH THE DOJ AND THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN THAT
WAS REPORTEDLY SCHEDULE FOR NEXT
WEEK.
THAT IS NOT HAPPENING.
WHY?
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO SEAT 1.2
MILLION DOLLARS CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND INFORMATION THEY
HAD BETTER THAN REQUESTING ABOUT
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
IT IS UNCLEAR YET MEET SUGGEST
NOT IS CLEAR THAT ROD,
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAVE BEEN
STONE WALLING CONGRESS EVERY
STEP.
THE DOJ IS TRYING TO SABOTAGE
THE WORK LIKE PEOPLE ARE DOING
WITH UM LEAKS.
THEY WANT A SLOW ROLE UNTIL MID
TERMS HOPING NANCY PEL LOSE AND
HE DEMOCRATS TAKE OVERNIGHT
HOUSE THEN THEY WILL NOT REVEAL
THIS.
ALSO TONIGHT FOX NEWS IS
LEARNING CONGRESS RECEIVED
INFORMATION FROM THE DOJ THAT
REQUESTED REGARDING COMBY'S
BUDDY THE PROFESSOR NOW HIS
ATTORNEY, HAD SPECIAL GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEE STATUS.
FORMER OBAMA D OJ OFFICIAL SHE
IS GOING AFTER THE PRESIDENT.
CLAIMING THAT HE IS CARRYING
DOWN THE LEGITIMACY OF THE DOJ.
SALE YOU ARE PROBABLY WATCHING.
YOU AND THE REST OF YOUR KROENES
YOU HAVE DONE ENOUGH DAMAGE AND
THE SAD PART IS RANK AND FILE
FBI, CIA, INTELLIGENCE THEIR
REPUTATIONS ARE SMEARED BECAUSE
OF OPERATIVES AT THE UPPER
ECHELON AND THE MISDEEDS THEY
DID NOW WE HAVE PRUNE ON THIS
SHOW.
MAY BE YOU ARE FORGETTING YOU
WERE E MAILING WITH MUELLER'S
PIT BULL ANDREW WEISSMAN
ANDIATES IS ONE OF THE CORRUPT
OFFICIALS THAT SIGNED OFF ON THE
FILESA WARRANT UNVERIFIED.
CONGRATULATIONS, SALLY.
YOU DID ENOUGH DAMAGE MORE THAN
ANY PRESIDENT COULD.
ONE MORE THING.
TRUMP CAN'TING JOHN BRENNON IS
CALLED OUT BY TWO COLLEAGUES
OVER HIS STATEMENTS ABOUT THE
CLINTON PAPERS.
PAUL RECOMMENDING THE TWO TOP
OFFICIALS ARE CONTRADICTING HIS
CLAIM THAT THEY DID NOT PLAY A
ROLE IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITIES ASSESS AM OF RUSSIAN
ELECTION MEDDLING.
FORMER NS ADIRECTOR TOLD
CONGRESS IT DID PLAY A ROLE IN
THE INTEL ASSESS AM.
AND THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE ADMITTED
SOMETHING SIMILAR.
WE KNOW CLAP AND BRENNON LIED.
I GUESS THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE
FROM A GUY WHO ONCE VOTED FOR
THE COMMUNIST FOR PEDESTRIAN
UNITED STATES.
HOW HE GOT THAT IS BEYOND ANY
UNDERSTANDING I HAVE.
TONIGHT, LAST THING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ON THE VERGE
OF ANOTHER VICTORY.
THIS IS GOOD NEWS FOR ALL OF US.
GINA NOW HAS THE VOTING TO BE
THE NEXT C OOH IA DIRECTOR THE
FACT IT TOOK THIS LONG FOR
DEMOCRATS TO SUPPORT HER IT IS
DISGRACEFUL ON THEIR PART.
SHE IS AN AMERICAN HERO.
HELPED KEEP US SAFE AFTER 911.
HELPED GET INTELLIGENCE TO FIND
BIN LADEN AND ANOTHER FACT,
ENHANCED INTERROGATION OF THE
THREE PEOPLE UNDER MEDICAL
INTRIGZ WORKED IT GAVE US THE
VALUABLE INTEL ALLOWED US TO GET
TO THE COURIER WHICH TOOK US TO